hi everyone and welcome to gamespot's
roundup of the best games from gamescom
2020. i'm lucy james joined by kelly
plaguei hello
and tomorrow he's saying no one is
allowed to have a bad time
it's gamescom it's gamescom we're two
for two and getting a reference to that
amazing song and when we're talking
about gamescom
very uh like obviously due to what's
happening in the world gamescom has been
completely
online this year we had jeff's opening
jeff keeley's opening night live on
thursday
where he showcased a bunch of new games
uh upcoming things as well
let's talk through what we thought were
the best so let's kick off with
call of duty black ops cold war cod
blops cow
so i genuinely this is the most
interested i've been in a card campaign
for years i'm very intrigued to see how
reagan
is gonna be a part of the whole thing
but at the same time i always think like
black ops campaigns have been the most
memorable at least for me
very interested to see more of that game
we're not gonna get a multiplayer reveal
for another few days
uh guys i'm gonna throw it to you what
do you think of the cold war reveal
within gamescom because it had already
been revealed the day before
yeah we got that like extended story
trailer
with the white house briefing we got and
robert redford for some reason
yeah more of a look at reagan
uh i i mean we knew a lot about the game
already so it's kind of hard to say
how much the gamescom presentation
really affected my impression of it
but i it was it was it was very
dramatic it was very intense um
which of course is to be expected for uh
call of duty but also the setting but um
i i was really drawn to it it reminded
me of the movie argo
all of the like pilot shades and like
the yeah we
remember we remember vietnam we just did
that so
i just it just gave me like argo vibes
for some reason
so that's really all i took out of it i
was gonna say i'm
interested in the uh the the what they
do with the storytelling because
they have the the kind of conspiracy
nothing is real everything's a psyop
kind of vibe going to it
um and i think this is the
raven software is kind of taking point
on uh on
the single player more than they have in
the past and that's a really interesting
studio they've been support
kind of on the bench for a while but
they used to make or they were more
prominently making really
weird and uh off bit off kill uh um
single player campaign so i'm interested
to see what they do i'm also interested
to see how they balance that psyops
you know stuff with actual history with
given around
you know around characters or figures
like reagan and stuff that happened
within the cold war and
you know famously cold war doesn't
involve a lot of like open
in in public battles how do they kind of
um
deal with that and and figure out the
line between them
it should be interesting yeah single
player wise it's probably the most i've
been interested in ecology in a while as
well
yeah i'm just really interested to see
because obviously we are going to be
replaying well it says we're going to be
going back to
uh you know vietnam as we as we players
experienced it within black ops like
1968 going back i wonder if we're going
to be
replaying those missions we obviously
know that we're going to be seeing some
familiar faces
if you did the war zone thing uh the
reveal you get to see
frank woods again don't know if res
enough is gonna make it back i don't
know if they're gonna be you know
shelling out the big bucks to bring gary
oldman back but i'm intrigued
nonetheless
um very excited to see more from
multiplayer because warzone has become
one of my go-to staples
let's move on unknown nine uh awakening
so unknown nine um the kind of blurb
about this game is that it's a
narrative driven adventure game for pc
and next gen
you're an outcast you have mysterious
powers
and you have a young girl named haruna
who discovers her supernatural abilities
during a confrontation with bullies a
classic uh
marvel uh x-men way to uncover your
powers the thing that's intriguing me
about this game though
is that it's set within a larger story
that's totally cross medium so there's
going to be uh comic books there's going
to be a podcast there's going to be a
full-length novel
which tam you and i know this only too
well being lost fans
is that that's where the cool stuff is
and like
yeah you have the edit do you have the
energy to get invested
again my my my first response to that is
like
i have no clue what this is like
unknown 9 is a very apt uh
title for a game that was revealed at
gamescom that we know very little about
but like i i think before i'm invested
in any sort of multi-um
discipline storytelling opportunities i
need to know what the story is and
actually care about that
i feel like if you're if you haven't got
a a core
amazing game out yet or a movie or a
comic or whatever
trying to be like we're going to tell
the story across different mediums
that's a very tricky proposition make me
care about any of these characters first
before you
or tell me what this game is before you
start telling me there's going to be
a comic book and a movie and a tv series
i'm going into with an open mind
there's definitely some but like even
the trailer that they showed off was
quite confusing because they focus on
one character and then it cut to the
kind of splash screen and there were
like four other people there i was like
who are any of these people
what's going on but um i'm into that
though i've been watching dark recently
i've been thinking about rewatching lost
i'm ready to go down the rabbit hole
yeah
see i i'm gonna say i probably won't
have the energy i will keep an open mind
but like danganronpa i love danganronpa
there's an anime that bridges the gap
between
two of the games there's comic books or
i guess you'd call it manga for
dangaraba but uh
i have not delved into that and i am a
huge dog in rampa fan like a fan of the
games
so if i haven't done that for
danganronpa it's gonna be really hard to
convince me to do that for something
else
so i'm just gonna say i will give it my
best shot
can't make any promises but it's an
interesting idea i do think it's like
a really it's because as a writer you
could craft such an interesting universe
across different media
um different media have different
storytelling opportunities so i do
appreciate the idea
it's just you gotta make sure the hook
is really there
for that to work um so like tam said
that's kind of what i'm waiting for to
see if
it'll grab me in that way that's fair
i'm j i'm just ready i'm ready to be
hurt again
let's move on to doom eternal the
ancient gods part one so we got to see
some more of
the upcoming expansion to do maternal
however i think the biggest takeaway
is that it's standalone you don't need
to have the base game in order to play
it does that make it a more intriguing
we talked on the pre-show that you know
we didn't like doing eternal
as much as we loved doom 2016 i know i
didn't finish it time i know you didn't
finish it either
we were talking about it at the weekend
too callie didn't finish it um
if uh ancient godspot 1 is it stand
alone is that gonna
put you over the line uh are you gonna
pick it up and play
that almost like hurts it for me because
i i think i said on the pre-show like i
always like an opportunity or an excuse
to revisit a game that i didn't have the
chance to finish a big part of the
reason i
didn't finish do maternal is because of
animal crossing and
uh you know now that i've kind of i mean
i haven't really stopped playing animal
crossing
at all but i've slowed down to the point
where i can have room
in my heart for other games uh so i
would have liked
an opportunity like an excuse to go back
um
through it and then to the to the
expansion dlc whatever you want to call
it this new
thing that's coming out um but
standalone is really nice if you haven't
beaten the game and then
you know there's no requirement to have
beaten it to play so i'm of two minds
about it
but i i i think i probably will go back
and like replay it to like get in the
groove
before i i get into the
the gods we'll see
that's fair time yeah i think a cheat
like if as long as it's a cheaper
alternative to buying doom
eternal at full price i think it makes
sense from a business perspective and
for bethesda you want to create as many
entry points into that game as possible
and if you can
get them into the dlc and they're like
oh i enjoyed this i'll get the full game
you're in business but for me personally
like um
i think i i'll go back to doom first and
see how
how i feel about that and see if i can
make it work for me again with like
better fov
and i'm not like one it's not making me
sick two
it's not like overstaying it's welcome i
feel like
there's a lot of fat in in eternal in a
way that
doesn't work for me like i liked how
lean 2016 was
but that was a time when there's a lot
of things to play um
so maybe now you know before the dlc
comes out where i've got a little more
space i might
fight with it a bit more and then decide
whether i want to play this base on that
however it does look cool
and i think if you're into doing
maternal and you're into those uh
hellish uh jumping around firing rocket
swipes then
um seems like it's more of that
or as i like to call it 2020.
all right this is this one is my
game of the show despite not playing it
or even it looking like it exists in any
playable form
however i did post a picture of it when
it uh when i saw the trailer on opening
night live
did not expect to see dragon h4 no like
dragon age 4 is such a weird one because
when i got teased at the game awards um
these are the jeffs the game awards of
the kiwis
when i got teased at the keeley's a
couple years ago i
it looked so early on in production it
was a pre-rendered thing
that you know someone threw together and
you know when was inquisition 2014
and so you know the heart beat strong
amongst the dragon age community we want
to have another game and so i just did
not expect to see it at gamescom
and it was another one of those classic
bioware
we are working on it we promised things
they did one for andromeda a few years
ago where just
you know the fancy shots of all the
developers and some concept art and
stuff
and i mean i think the biggest takeaway
from the dragon age 40s is that
obviously solas is back it's gonna be a
continuation of that storyline
no spoils if you haven't played it um
even if you weren't that big
on dragon age uh inquisition the
trespasser dlc
and the reveal that came at the end of
that like imagine
living on a cliffhanger like that for
five years it's not a good time
it's not a good time not a good time um
so
as soon as i saw casey hudson pop up on
screen i think i was messing with you
i was like um excuse me it's got to be
one of two things
and either way it's like lose our stuff
like that
but yeah i think i think it was as far
as like
we're gonna reveal nothing for a minute
and a half goes
it's it was pretty good at that because
it showed off their ethos we got like
some concept art of soulless like
pulling faces and looking like a goof
which was like looking like an
angry egg yeah i was like there he is
that troublemaker
um but yeah it's it they talked about
how they're approaching it and what kind
of themes they want to hear
and i think they mentioned a bunch and
like uh alluded to
a bunch of old-school like dragon age
developers coming back like mike dorad
and a few others like that so as far as
dragon age fans go
it was a whole lot of nothing but still
quite
um like confidence boosting in that one
they're working on it
two they've got a clear idea three um
they have got some like old school
talent back on board to help the
kind of current team who are more than
capable of it but
it's good to have that you know someone
who knows and can steer the ship
um into our one so yeah good job on
telling us nothing but making us excited
yeah i feel i feel like when you put it
like that i'm like damn
they really got me yeah again yeah i
just think of that meme like go girl
give us nothing
is really that i was gonna say my
favorite part was the pulling faces yeah
because i have no investment in dragon
age i've never played a dragon age i
would like to
um but the at the pulling faces i had a
i had a good chuckle
at that part that's good all right let's
take a quick break we'll be right back
with the rest of our show
as we know gamescom reaches gamers far
and wide
check out this short video from the army
national guard highlighting their
favorite moments from gamescom
hi i'm staff sergeant murray with the
army national guard here are my
highlights from gamescom
pretty excited we have light at the end
of the tunnel world of warcraft's newest
expansion
shadowlands hits october 27th got the
goosebumps for the animated short
afterlives during gamescom did you see
uther and arthas
it's not vengeance it's justice
i got pretty pumped up over that i've
just got to figure out if i'll be trash
on my rogue or
trash on my hunter for shadowlands
either way for the horde
we got to see more gameplay footage of
star wars squadrons we saw the imperial
mission
behind enemy lines i'm looking forward
to playing this in vr on my oculus rift
s
but speaking of vr the biggest surprise
for me from gamescom
medal of honor above and beyond we
haven't seen a medal of honor title in
eight years this one will be fully
immersive in vr
and includes vr exclusives i'm pretty
excited but that's just my highlights
find me on the rest of the army national
guard gamers on twitch
all right we're back let's talk about
crash bandicoot 4
it's about time and yeah it's about time
is such an apt
description because if you like
us and grew up with crash bandicoot
throughout the 90s
you've basically been waiting since was
it 1999 or something since three
for a good crash bandicoot game yes they
remastered it
and feels like it was way more difficult
in the remaster than it was when i was a
kid or maybe i was just some kind of
child pro
like prodigy platformers
but when i was playing uh like the crash
remake a couple years ago i was like i
could just really go for a new crash and
that's what they're doing
finally i got revealed over the summer
and we're going to see another look at
it we're going to see
flashback tapes which are a kind of
reference to the really old no hit
you had to like get the no death gems uh
in the old games i'm very excited for
this one
guys are you reveling in the crash uh
reveal as much as i am
i feel like it's just me i mean i i
never was into crash in particular
the the thing for me is i wonder what
the staying power is
of this style of platformer because uh
there's been a lot of attempts at like
rekindling that
magic that we all had in the 90s with
this kind of platformer and like
collecting things and and that kind of
feel uh lucky's tale which was a vr game
originally um you had like ukulele
kind of trying to rekindle the
banjo-kazooie hype and and i've played a
lot of those platformers and i just
never
i haven't felt that magic since so
i wonder what the like what can
it's about time do to kind of rekindle
that for us
because um you know that was it's a
bygone era in a lot of ways
i think for us it's very nostalgic i
wonder about like how does that
for someone who's never played a
platformer like that or never played a
crash game like i have
how do you get people into that so
that's kind of my hesitation with this
game is
is just the track record of that
collect-a-thon platformer
style in the last couple years i'm
really curious though
yeah i think of all the playstation
mascot platformer games like crash is
easily my favorite um and i played those
first three games to death as well as
crash team racing
but i think what kind of makes it gives
this specific game more potential is
like the the canvas
for creativity is like way more open for
this particular franchise
like spyro is great and sly is great but
there's like they're kind of limited in
what you can do
you could say the same for like um
ratchet and clank to some degree though
maybe the time hopping is a bit more um
open
now but like crash bandicoot you can do
some real weird and wacky things with
that franchise like they have done that
stuff before
and it's got a lot of humor in it and it
seems like they're leaning into it which
is good
this actually showing that they should
the stuff that they showed off was like
another trip
feed like a droplet of information um i
really want them to just come out and
give us like a big
like gameplay demo of an entire level to
show us you know
the interesting things that they're
doing and how it all works together
i love the idea of doing like a one hit
like no hit um
kind of requirement to get this special
level but how does that work within the
game itself like
you know how what these levels like and
how are you traveling around them that's
what i want to
know i also want to take the time to
just remind everyone that we had a video
game this year that had the phrase smash
bandy's cooch in it
thank you
how how can you throw that back to me as
a link i can't believe you've done this
one thing i will say is uh before we
move on for crash bandicoot is
obviously when you take a beloved
platformer like that that so many like
an entire generation of people grew up
with
you can't just you know you have to put
your own spin on it and toys for bob
have taken that art style and put
such a good spin on it i really love the
way that the characters are looking and
i'm very very excited for more
crash let's move on star wars had
quite a showing at gamescom this year
it's very strange to me because i feel
like star wars maybe should have been
bigger
last year just before ryze skywalker
came out
and you know definitely before rise of
skywalker came out and you know
it crushed all our dreams but so we had
star wars squadrons we had uh
lego star wars the skywalker saga as
well as the sims
4 journey to batu which
let's let's just take star wars is like
a whole thing uh guys i'm gonna throw it
to you
what was the one that you were most
excited for sims 4 for sure baby
i can't believe that
the last pack that we had was nifty
knitting like and then we're just going
full stop
just two very different worlds
for the very different ends of the sim
spectrum there
in all seriousness seriousness though i
do think like there is a market for
a star wars game that isn't combat
focused yeah i think like
like i have definitely a soft spot for
kotor and i really like
you know like the old battlefront games
i i like
star wars games with combat but i do
think there's more to the star wars
universe than
combat and so you can kind of get
creative with it
with the sims 4. it does seem like an
obvious disneyland tie-in though because
it's very much based
on galaxy's edge um but i still think
that's fun like having the cantina and
it's interesting i was not expecting
this at all i
really it came out of left field for me
i like couldn't believe what i was
looking at
so um i'm intrigued by it for sure
i don't it seems like one of those sims
expansions where you like go
off to a place and do your thing and
then you come back to
your normal you know the goths and the
whatever you go back to your normal town
but um
should be exciting i'm very
very very intrigued by it also it's
you know the sims has never shied away
from doing these tie-ins before
obviously we've had
but they've more like been stuff packs
right you know
katy perry ikea uh h m
but never had something as uh quite as
involved as this one so i'm very excited
about it tam what about you in terms of
star wars games
this year definitely squadrons like i'm
very excited like kelly said like combat
is
um there's a lot of room for experiences
that aren't
combat um for me like i take that one
step deeper and say like there's a lot
of room for experiences that aren't
lightsaber combat because um
we're not great at getting that right um
let's just focus on the
the thing that we can probably get super
good um which is the
uh combat in in in space in the skies um
and that stuff is looking amazing um
especially with the uh story
stuff that's uh kind of threaded in
between i'm glad they're doubling down
on telling a story so it's been like
here's a bunch of skirmish scenarios um
and then
you know it's a cheaper game more
focused experience so
i've got a lot of high hopes for um
squadrons
dude if i didn't think i would need to
take a dramamine to play that game i
would be right there with you
i am just so nervous about puking 100
i i'm sure that i will be throwing up
non-stop but i'm not trying
well the thing is is that like because
of microsoft flight simulator or the
flight sticks
are sold out and if anything is going to
make me want to
you know get a flight stick it would
probably be star wars squadrons so
hopefully they're going to be on back
order and they'll be back in stock by
the time the squadrons comes out
it's not actually that long to wait
either which is great uh let's move on
to 4 guys season two so
four guys feel good hit of the summer
taking the world by storm
uh such a smart move putting it on
playstation plus got a little hint
about season two what we can expect to
see so
new cosmetics medieval themed uh which
reminded me a lot tam this one's for you
of it's a knockout oh yeah
if like season one was takeshi's castle
season two is it's a knockout and i can
only hope that season three is gonna be
the crystal maze yeah oh my god that
would be good and media tonic are a
british developer so
no doubt they've been thinking about
like 80s and 90s game shows to tie in
four players after that let's roll
i actually knew somebody went on are you
guys
are you guys punking me right now these
are real
tv shows do you like this
that's a tangent we'll talk about later
but i love the way
that it just takes these influences and
just wears them on its sleeve
uh i'm very excited about the costumes
because i'm now at the stage where i'm
actually getting better at the game and
i can unlock some stuff
i really want to be that little wizard
guy i love him
yeah i i really want better costumes i
split my play time between
ps4 and pc depending on like who i if i
want to play by myself i was just
playing on ps4 but i was playing like
with people on pc
um so i just i i have nothing i have
nothing good
i would love to be a cool dragon or
something i would also love some new
rounds
not a fan of some of the team games no
team team games
no one likes the team games they're yes
tail tag lasts way too long so i was
mostly looking for that
i was like what are some of the new
brands how are we evolving
this concept to to a better place
because i think there's something like a
really good foundation in fall guys and
i think it could just use
some tweaks so that's what i was excited
about is the prospect of new rounds
yeah i think theming your um updates
around
certain things is a very shrewd move
that they've clearly picked off uh
fortnight so
they're basically very carefully paying
attention and
planning out their moves which is going
to bode well for that game
very excited for the inevitable marvel
tie-in um
right let's move on we haven't got long
left let's talk about destiny 2
beyond light so i didn't i honestly
expected to see
more but they are kind of timing the
um the more in-depth granular stuff um
per class uh later on down the line
i'm still on the fence as to whether
this is gonna be the thing to get me
back into destiny too
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i like i
i just need i really need good hooks
these days
to to get me off my ass and like
like actually playing a game sometimes
and like i do think
um the the new like
stasis i think um is is really
intriguing i'm i'm definitely waiting to
hear more about specifically like
what hunter will look like because
that's the class i play but
um yeah it'll it'll take a lot i'll
probably jump back in just because
i find like the shooting so satisfying
that it can just kind of be a relaxing
thing for me
um yeah i'm not sure
time what about you yeah i think i think
it looks good like i think it looks
more like um for for people who
are very in the trenches river right now
it would have been good to
i imagine bungie's going to do this
separately on their own terms but like
do another pitch for people who aren't
already invested and
and get them in for people like you who
might be like why would i why do i want
to get back into this right now
that that trailer alone feels like it's
like in the middle of the story
and in the middle of a content update
that you you would feel a bit lost
and you wouldn't really have any reason
to get excited about
but nevertheless i know that there's a
bunch of people
on our team that saw that and were like
yeah that looks cool um
destiny slack lit up yeah everyone was
excited about new content
uh these days i can't tell if they're
excited about the content or if they
excited that there is content um so
sometimes like i'm like i don't know you
guys but uh sure
um but yeah i'm gonna check it out a bit
um
but i hope that bungie does a bit more
to invite new players and that's what
they've got to do to keep that community
strong
yeah all right let's talk about ratchet
and clank
rift apart like did you guys see the
screenshots comparing
uh that demo from the was it june ps5
event
or july ps5 event today because it's
seriously very impressive i have never
really been a ratchet and clank player
before
um but honestly this is taking all the
right boxes for me it's colorful it's
cute
the gameplay looks just like super quick
and just a game that you can sort of dip
in and out of as well at the same
time like i'm very excited about this
um tam what about you yeah i mean like
the last ratchet game that they released
that was
based around the movie and perhaps you
didn't get as much attention as it
deserves is fantastic like it's
really really good and i think it's
pretty cheap on ps4 now so if you're in
the if you're seeing this and you're
like in the mood for it
highly recommend that one it's a good
time um but like
this this looks like they're doubling
down on what makes those games
interesting the weird quirky gameplay
hooks and and leaning into the odd
weapons
and so i'm excited to see more of that
stuff that's what insomniac does best
and um they showed off a bit more about
how the kind of like warp gates work and
how they
uh utilize the playstation 5
architecture a bit more and it was
impressive you could see
um ratchet kind of hooking in uh pause
and then immediately being in different
altogether like distinct worlds um that
looked really exciting
and really cool and then we got another
hint at the second lombax character the
female longbox
um who is she who is she
is she um i like her little tuft of hair
um
but i need to know more about her before
i start writing up
fan art writing up fan art
yeah whatever it was writing up
i was going somewhere way more
inappropriate and then i had to like
handbrake turn
all right uh cali any thoughts on
ratchet clang before we go on to our
personal picks for what we loved from
gamescom this year
my main thing was who is she so we
covered that
all right what was your pick uh from
gamescom this year
cali uh probably sims 4
journey to bed too just because i was
like completely blindsided by that i
really was not expecting that
i i loved the sims i i needed another
thing to reinvigorate my love of the
sims and and like that you know like
when you just like you feel like i could
play the sims for eight hours and i need
to do that right now
um that's that's the hit i'm looking for
so i was really excited
tam what about you uh i think i'm most
invested in the deep dark void of my
heart that exists because elder ring
still hasn't shown up anymore oh i'm
sorry man
yeah are you gonna be making your own
version make make elden ring in dreams
no i'm just constantly tweeting at from
software and kind of
help me why are you doing this to me
yeah what have you done give us anything
uh well for me uh ghost runner is
getting a beta that i'm 100 registering
for because that game looks awesome
but i think honestly my favorite game
from gamescom this year 12 minutes
again didn't really need to see much of
it i just love the premise already i
love the aesthetic but also they
announced the voice cast
and holy crap uh willem dafoe
james mcavoy daisy ridley uh
if you've been listening to sandman on
audible you know how incredible james
mcavoy
is at voiceover work as on top of being
a great actor so
i'm all in on that game with the shining
carpet
cali tam thank you so much for joining
me where can people find you
you can find me on twitter at inkydojico
i-n-k-y-d-o-j-i-k-k-o
you'll find me on twitter h t-a-m-o-r-h
constantly adding from software yeah uh
and i'm on twitter at lucy james games
we'll see you next time
you